have you heard rich people in movies
time and time again describe how they
keep most of their money in Swiss bank
is this actually true in real life and
if so what's all the hubbub about
Switzerland well it is true that Swiss
banks are arguably the best banks to
keep your money and not just for the
rich but for everyone if you're not
investing it of course so here's why
Swiss banks are so highly sought after
starting with extreme privacy Swiss
banks have built up an indestructible
reputation for privacy as they simply
will not reveal your identity for any
reason except for illegal pursuits now
don't get too impressed as this is not
from the goodness of their heart or
outstanding integral practices after the
Swiss banking law of 1934 was passed it
was made a criminal for Swiss banks to
even disclose a name of an account
holder but privacy alone wouldn't
attract so many people to invest in
Swiss banks though it is a great feature
a lot of wealthy folks are intrigued by
Swiss banks due to their very high
interest rates while actually not really
Swiss banks have some of the worst
interest rates in the world
in fact they occasionally charge
negative interest rates meaning that you
have to pay the bank to keep your money
there so Swiss banks don't have good
interest rates but what they do have is
a great return on investments or are
wise wait how can Swiss banks offer a
great return on investment when they
averaged about zero percent interest
well the secret lies in their shockingly
low inflation rate over the past 20
years
Switzerland has actually experienced
five years with negative inflation or
deflation this means that their currency
has become more valuable year after year
now prolonged periods of deflation are
terrible for a country as it indicates
weak economic growth but in the case of
Switzerland it's not too bad in the 20
year period between 1999 and
2018 that average inflation rate in
Switzerland was actually only 0.51 5%
compared to the global average inflation
rate of about 3% in the same period the
world actually had an average inflation
rate of three point four four percent
but this does include the global
financial crisis so we'll give them the
benefit of the doubt and give them an
inflation rate of three percent this
means that every year the Swiss currency
gains about 2.5 percent in value
compared to the average currency this
makes sense as if you take a look at the
USD the Swiss franc conversion rate
you'll see that in 2003 you can get one
point three seven Swiss francs using a
US dollar but today you can't even get a
full Swiss franc using a US dollar to
really put this in perspective using at
ROI of 2.5 percent which is the 3
percent global inflation rate minus a
point 5 percent inflation rate in
Switzerland in the last 20 years by
simply placing your money in a Swiss
bank in the Swiss franc currency you
would have gained sixty three point nine
percent in value in just a little more
than eight years your money would have
doubled now of course that would have
taken a total of twenty eight point five
years but you have to keep in mind that
this is simply a savings account not
real estate or mutual funds or index
funds
despite this what's so impressive is
that this comes close to the ROI of the
real investments mutual funds which are
considered to be one of the safer
investments averaged about seven percent
after mutual fund manager fees when take
out inflation this comes down to four
percent which is quite comparable to
Swiss banks ROI of two point five
percent of course wealthy people didn't
become wealthy settling for two point
five percent are wise and they should
for at least ten percent or less real
estate or high return mutual funds
however this makes Swiss banks the
perfect place to keep money between
investments due to their unbeatable
stability real estate may go through a
housing bubble or crash the stock market
may experience a bull market or bear
market they do end up averaging a much
better return on investment over the
long term but the same cannot be said in
the short-term as a result oftentimes
for periods of just a couple of months
it makes much more sense to put
investment money into a Swiss bank
rather than others or investment even
during the worst of recessions the Swiss
currency has proven to hold strong if
you didn't look close at the Switzerland
inflation graph you may have not even
noticed a peak in the inflation rate
during the 2008 global financial crisis
Switzerland only experienced an
inflation rate of two point four three
percent during the global financial
crisis which is still well under the
global average inflation rate of three
percent meanwhile the global inflation
rate peaked at eight point nine to six
percent in 2008 meaning that on average
you would have had a six point five
percent ROI by simply keeping your money
in a Swiss bank rather than an average
bank during that year and this was
during a time when the S&P 500 over half
the single year and real estate prices
plummeted again those did recover and
have ended up doing better than a two
point five percent ROI but this
showcases the stability of Swiss banks
even on the short term in the end Swiss
banks don't actually offer anything
special that system apart other than
their great privacy policies what
actually attracts investment is the
Swiss economy which has proven to be one
of the most if not the most stable
economy in the world with little to no
inflation this has made Swiss banks the
perfect opportunity to preserve the
value of once money and retained
purchasing power by avoiding inflation
in their home country and that is why
rich people love to keep money which
they have not already sunk into
investments in Swiss banks but the
benefits don't just apply to rich people
you could and should definitely take
advantage of their strong economy don't
use them as an investment platform but
definitely explore the option of using
Swiss banks as a place to keep your
onion
money whether just a couple of friend or
tens of thousands of dollars anyways if
you guys thought this video explained
that pillow Swiss banks well then major
drop a like and consider subscribing if
I could see more questions just like
this one
logically answered but until then I'm
Horry I'll see you guys on the next one